ok coupé elle est bonne ok nickel la
lune c'est bon tu peux leur pied on n'a
plus besoin ce qu'on peux m'étendre le
soleil là il fait chaud le soleil on
peut faire un son sol oui tu veux oui ok
merci tout le monde c'était le dernier
plan de tous les habitants de la terre
c'était un projet ambitieux ou il
n'avait plus de 3 milliards d'années de
rush et on a dû en faire un film de deux
cent mille ans au final donc le montage
est un processus assez long et
l'élaboration d'un tel projet ça prend
beaucoup de temps
en fait le plus long c'était la
construction des décors ça nous a pris à
peu près un milliard d'années avant de
trouver un truc un peu un peu potable et
après on a dû attendre c'est bon c'est
bon il ya de la vie moi j'aime bien les
dinosaures mais la production ne mettais
pas mal de pression parce que ça coûtait
trop cher
c'était pas assez intéressant du coup
j'ai dû j'ai dû les virer mais après il
est humain et là bas c'est intéressant
alors justement comment on peut raconter
une histoire avec autant personnages
incroyables
alors c'est sûr c'est pas évident de
raconter sur 7000 heures d'histoire mais
chaque vie était différente chaque vie
avait sa singularité et était très
intéressant vraiment sauf celle des de
remoulins luge l'enlever du film comment
est-ce que vos rapports avec vos
comédiens
il ya au départ j'avais un scénario
décrit mais je suis aujourd'hui
réalisateur déjà qui récrit pas mal
chantournage et au bout d'un moment je
me suis aperçu que j'avais plus besoin
avant d'écrire parce que les humains
proposer des choses vraiment vraiment
incroyable en chanteurs venus
quelquefois au début par ci par là pour
leur donner des indications jeu ce que
je voulais qu'ils fassent qui fasse pas
mais j'ai très vite arrêté parce que
déjà il faisait des guerres en mon nom
ça c'était vraiment chaud et pour les
laisser se débrouiller entre eux parce
que ça reste dans l'histoire c'est pas
la mienne
justement votre meilleur souvenir de
tournage j'ai pas de souvenir en
particulier les humains sont des êtres
très intéressant je les ai connus à
l'état de petit organisme et je les ai
vus grandir jusqu'à arriver à une espèce
qui cherche à comprendre d'où elle vient
et chercher à expliquer et à savoir ils
n'arrêtaient pas de nous surprendre et
proposer des choses vraiment vraiment
incroyable sauf eux est donc maintenant
toutes ces vies si différente avait au
final les mêmes thèmes la recherche du
bonheur l'amour là mort très intéressant
leur rapport à la mort et c'est un pur
bonheur pour un réalisateur de voir une
histoire se construire d'elle-même petit
à petit et les voir tous lutter pour
s'occuper des gens qu'ils aiment votre
pire souvenir de tournage c'est lequel
plus belle la vie ça c'était horrible
alors maintenant la question tout le
monde se pose parce qu'il aura une suite
écoutez on se concentre sur la promo du
film en ce moment mais mais en tout cas
en tout cas l'envié est là oui étonné
que les humains sont aller coloniser
notre planète
on peut raconter leur histoire et ça
peut être vachement intéressant et puis
maintenant les humains ils ont des
sabres laser et tous de quoi on peut
faire des trucs ultra stylée merci
beaucoup et bravo parce que je crois que
c'était pas évident jury cac
tu viens ba a commencé à y aller je vous
rejoins